>> T. C. Boyle: Good afternoon, you Googleites
and everybody else out there in the world.
Thanks for joining me for lunch. I don't know
what you're having. I'm having sugarless gum,
actually, for lunch today. But it's not unusual.
I come from a family where my wife never leaves
the couch for any reason and she is on a new
diet and this is how I'm going to make my
true fortune.
I'm gonna write a diet book. I, by the way,
I could be the after. It works for her. She's
been on it for two years. It's the all-you-can-eat
meat and all-you-can-drink wine diet. And
she's up to about a herd a week and a gallon
a day.
[laughter]
And maybe a visit to the Betty Ford Clinic
eventually. But at this point, she is as slim
and sweet as the girl I first married. And
I should point out that I am the only writer
in history who only had one wife. But that's
OK. She helps me with my research. So that
whenever I'm researching a book, she gets
deeply involved with all the same materials
that I do.
And she gets very passionate about it. And
then, of course, I have to write the book
for the next year and she forgets entirely
about it. She was most helpful to me when
I did my book 'The Inner Circle', which came
out in 2004. This is about Alfred C. Kinsey,
who invented sex and she went with June Bloomington
and Diana with me and we went to the Kinsey
Institute.
And we studied all the various arcane sexual
things he's got there. And then, of course,
she helped me with the research. She's continuing
to help me with the research for that one.
And she also helped me with the research for
the current book, which is what brings me
here. 'When The Killing's Done'. As long as
I'm talking about her, she has a mother, my
wife. My mother-in-law.
My mother-in-law has always been a little
bit horrified by me as if I'm some kind of
crazy beast. But you can see that I'm not.
I'm just the most sweet guy in the world.
So that, for the first 20 years, for instance,
she'd be visiting us, sitting. She'd be sitting
in the kitchen, I'd come down for breakfast
and she would jump up from the chair and say,
"My God, does he sit here?" I'd say, 'No.
It's okay. It's all right. She can sit there.'
Now we've come to a little bit of a rapprochement
and it works this way. She lives in Arizona
and I will never in the rest of my life ever
go to Arizona for any reason. And she only
comes to visit when I'm away. That's great.
It's perfect. However, when I do see her she
says, "You are so lucky." And in fact, I am
lucky because whenever I wanna discover something,
I just write a book about it. This is the
way my brain works. I write fiction. I only
write fiction.
That's all I do. And so, 18 years ago I made
my escape from LA and moved to Santa Barbara.
I still though, teach one day a week at USC.
I'm the first writer they ever had there.
I started the undergrad writing program. I
love it. It's a great thing. But it's a hundred
miles each way. By the way, I have a red sports
car. See, red is my color.
[laughter]
And I don't enjoy it in the slightest bit.
It's only a tool, like a screwdriver for instance.
And the tool enables me to get between the
blind, deaf, semi-retarded, drunken woman
in the Mercedes Benz texting in the fast lane
doing 40 miles an hour with a trucker right
here. And there's usually a gap about this
big. And this little sports car, you can kick
the gas to the floor, it's just like its Star
Wars. Boom! And you see them fading in the
rear-view mirror.
[laughter]
So this is my life. And all these years of
going up the Coast Highway, I always go through
Malibu and up the Coast Highway looking at
the ocean instead of through the valley. I've
seen the Channel Islands sitting off the Coast,
wondering what goes on out there. Now I know.
[pause]
As you may know, the Channel Islands is a
national park now. But these islands were
originally owned by individuals for many,
many years. And they use them for sheep ranching.
So that the big dumb island sitting off of
Santa Barbara, 22 miles off the coast, is
Santa Cruz Island. It's four times bigger
than Manhattan.
Nobody lives there. As recently as the late
80s, it was owned, 95 percent of it was owned
by a very wealthy guy who was the son of an
oil trillionaire. And his name was Gary Stanton.
He owned this island. Now there's a main ranch
and there were some outlying ranches and this
was used for sheep. They would sell the wool
and they would sell lambs and so on. Gary
Stanton, on his death, ceded it to the Nature
Conservancy, 90 percent of the island. The
other ten percent is a National Park right
now. This was owned by a different family.
But it's all now trying to be restored. And
what I've written about, 'When the Killing's
Done', is this restoration process. It began
in 2001 on Anacapa Island. What I'm gonna
tell you now is my fiction. What I have done
is dramatize actual events. So all of what
I'm going to tell you actually happened.
So in 2001, the Park Service decided to bomb
Anacapa Island with rat poison. Brodifacoum,
the same stuff that anybody, this thing or
out there has had a heart attack, that's the
stuff that doctors give you. It's the same
stuff in d-Con that you put in your traps.
The rest had gotten to Anacapa in 1853 with
the wreck of the Winfield Scott.
This is a paddle-wheel steamer coming out
of San Francisco with a bunch of passengers
who would eventually go to the East Coast,
to New York. A lot of them were 49ers who'd
been out in the back country and had their
gold and they had made their fortune and they
were on their way back home. The boat would
go to Panama. There was no Panama Canal yet,
and they'd trek across and take another steamer
up the East Coast.
Well, they didn't make it. They didn't make
it on this particular occasion because the
boat, in tremendous fog, went aground on Anacapa
Island. No one died. Everyone was rescued
after a couple of days. Of course, they did
have to forage for food. One guy shot a seal.
You can imagine what seals taste like. They
were rescued. The gold was rescued. Everything
was great.
But the ship went down and all the rats got
ashore. And now, 150 years later in 2001,
the Park Service decided to remove the rats.
Why? Well, because the ground-nesting birds
there had evolved in the absence of predators
and the rats were decimating their numbers.
Even after all this time, they were eating
their eggs and killing the nestlings. All
right. So the Park Service decided to go out
in November of 2001, and with helicopters
and drop rat poison all over the island.
And they said there'd be no collateral damage.
The native white-footed mouse, they captured
a bunch of them and they were breeding them
separately. The birds are not gonna eat it
'cause it's bright blue. If you know d-Con
pellets, it's bright blue. However, there
were some protests. And in actual fact, there
was a guy called the Rat Savior and he protested
this. He went out with a confederate to Anacapa
when this was underway with huge backpacks
full of Kibble and Vitamin K, because Vitamin
K is the antidote to brodifacoum.
And I created a character based on this guy,
whom I've never met. I just read about this
in the newspaper. And my character's named
Dave Lajoy. And he's one of the two antagonists
in this novel. He's 42 years old in 2001.
He wears his hair in dreadlocks. He's a pretty
cool guy, at least in his own mind. And he's
made his money with four stores that he owns
that sell stereo and audio and audiovisual
equipment. And he is a very, very, very angry
guy, one of these people who’s angry about
everything. But his one defining subject is
animal rights.
And he feels that no animal should be killed
for any reason. He's opposed meanwhile to
a character I created called Alma Boyd Takesue,
and she works for the Park Service. And she's
in charge of this operation to remove the
rats and later, to remove other feral animals
on Santa Cruz Island, which I'll get to in
a minute. And she is just like him. I mean,
they both love animals. They love the environment.
They want to preserve everything. But she
is intransigent.
There can't be any killing of anything, even
a rat. But she indulges in rail impolitic.
She feels that certain invasive species can
be removed, must be removed, in order to preserve
the much rarer species that will go extinct
if they're not removed. And so that forms
the basis of all of what goes on in this book.
In actual life and in my novel, and we'll
call him not the real guy, the actual guy,
we're just gonna talk about Dave Lajoy.
He was arrested with his confederate for feeding
wildlife in a National Park without a permit.
And his buddy, by the way, cops to it and
got a 150 dollar fine or something, because
they're both dressed in black with hoodies
and black baseball caps. And they were seen
by a Park Ranger on Anacapa. They were the
only people there that day. But in a court
of law, they couldn't be proven that he had,
which one he saw throwing the stuff cause
they were both dressed exactly alike.
So, Dave Lajoy got off on this count. Then,
and by the way, I mean this all sounds so
theoretical. Believe me, in my telling, it
is full of filth, horror,
[audience laughter]
various degrees of slime, misery and antagonism,
and you also learn about the island and about
geography. In fact, my favorite review of
this book said that this "is the first island
biogeographical thriller." Yeah, I'm so happy
about it. I'm sure there'll never be a second
one.
[laughter]
Before I tell you the rest of the story, maybe
I will give you a very brief reading of Dave
Lajoy. He's very, very, very angry at all
times. And in this tiny little passage I'm
going to give you, takes place the day after
Dave has interrupted Alma's meeting.
She, by the way, I've read that in America,
people's greatest fear is not of spiders bigger
than your head or Islamic terrorists or brain
cancer. It is of speaking before a large group
in public. And Alma has to do this. And you
see the previous chapter from her point of
view. She's explaining to people at the Natural
History Museum, concerned citizens, what this
is all about.
And Dave has come to interrupt and jeer at
her. And, in fact, when she leaves the meeting
after he's been ejected, her car has, spray
painted across it, "Die Gook Bitch." Now,
we don't know who spray painted that, but
we have our suspicions. And so, the next day,
I'll just give you a very brief account of
Dave. He's having breakfast the next day and
he's looking in the newspaper to see what
account they gave of his interrupting this
meeting.
[pause]
Can I use language here that I couldn't use
on NPR by any chance?
>>Female Presenter: We'll just put a warning
on the video. If we could put a warning on
the video.
>> T. C. Boyle: I'm pretty good at it. I mean,
I could substitute terms like 'crap' for 'shit',
but it’s not as good because this is the
way Dave just does it, you know? So I'm gonna
give you just a little bit of language. This
is Dave just having breakfast, very angry
guy.
[reads passage]
"If there's one thing he hates, it’s a runny
yolk. And toast so dry it shatters like a
cracker before you can spread the butter.
And rain, he hates the rain, too. Three days
of it now, making a mess on the streets and
keeping shoppers out of the stores; pathetic
numbers, absolutely pathetic. And all four
units with the Christmas season coming on,
no less. Depressing people; drooling like
bilge down the plate glass window at the Cactus
Cafe where he eats breakfast five days a week
and they still can't figure out what over-fucking-easy
means. His dried out toast is cold. The coffee
tastes like aluminum foil and its cold, too.
Or lukewarm at best.
And the newspaper has one stingy little article
about what went down at the museum last night,
tucked away in the community events round-up
for Tuesday, November 20, 2001. The date in
bolder type than the headline, as if to indicate
how mind-numbing and inconsequential everything
had been as it had been the day before and
the day before that. Under the headline, 'Protest
at Museum Lecture', there's a scant two paragraphs
that don't begin to get at the issue. And
worse, it don't even mention him or FDA by
name, let alone set out the counterarguments
he'd thrown right in the face of that condescending
little bitch from the Park Service, who was
fooling nobody with her grey-eyed squint and
her all-black outfit as if she were going
to a funeral or a goth club or something.
And all her tricked up images of the cute
little animals that just have to be saved
in the face of this sudden onslaught by all
these other ugly little animals, made uglier
by somebody's Photoshop manipulations. As
if the birds wouldn't last another week when
150 years ago [audience member sneezes] lived
in complete harmony and natural balance with
all the other birds and plants, and the rats,
too. Something Alma Boyd Takesue, Ph. D.,
didn't bother to mention.
Suddenly, he's jerking his head around and
there's Marta, fat Marta with her two ton
tits and big pregnant belly that isn't pregnant
at all, only just fat, bending over some other
guy's table by the door, flirting with him,
for Christ's sake. And before he could think,
he shouts out her name, surprising himself
by the violence of his voice. Everybody in
the place, and there must be 30 of them, half
he recognizes and half not, looks up in unison
as if they were all named Marta. And what
did he think about that? He thinks, "Fuck
you," collectively. He thinks he might have
to find another goddamned diner where they
know the difference between, and here she
is. Her face drawn down around her mouth shrunk
to the size of a keyhole beneath the flabby
cheeks, coming to him as swiftly as her two
small feet can carry her, trying to act as
if she cares.
"Is everything OK?" she asks before she's
halfway to him, so everybody can hear her
doing her job. Even Francisco, the cook, who's
giving him a hooded look from behind the grill,
a cigarette in one hand and a spatula in the
other. "No," he says, still too loud. And
they're still looking, all of them. Because
they're a bunch of sad-ass, pathetic voyeurs
with nothing better to do and fuck them, really,
fuck them.
"No, everything isn't OK. It's like I come
in here every day, don't I? And you people
still don't know what over easy means? Shit,
if I wanted sunny side up, if I wanted a runny
yolk that's what I would've ordered." She's
already reaching for the plate, already apologizing,
"Sorry, sir. I'll have the cook--” and all
the rest of the mollifying, meaningless, little
phrases she dispenses a hundred times a day
because the cook's a moron and to call her
incompetent would be a compliment.
But he can't help saying, snarling, and why
is he snarling? "Take it away and get it right,
or don't do it at all." And, to the retreating
twin hummocks of her butt, "And the toast
is like that shit they give babies. What do
you call that? Zwieback? And I don't want
Zwieback, I want toast!"
She's at the swinging door to the kitchen
now, making a show of upending the plate in
the trash while Francisco shrinks into the
Aztecan nullity of his face, and everybody
else in the place pretends to take up their
conversations where they left off. And he
can't help adding, his voice lower now, the
rage all steamed out of him though the heat
still up high, "Simple toast. Is that too
much to ask?"
[ends passage]
So, that was your introduction to Dave from
his point of view and, of course, what novelists
love to do is have opposing points of view
and you get deep into each of the antagonists
and how they feel.
And Dave, he's not a nice guy. He's a boor.
He's a bully. He's angry. But he does have
a good point. He is against the killing of
anything. Alma, on the other [audience member
sneezes] side, is rational but she's also
very intransigent and a little uptight and
a little stiff. And maybe neither one of them
is exactly the most wonderful person in the
world. But I mean aside from present company,
nobody else is either, right? One further
little note about Dave. You might hear some
of this tonight when he comes in. Is that
all right?
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah.
>> T. C. Boyle: Yeah. 'Cause it's a shtick.
[Boyle laughs]
>>Male Audience Member #1: I won't say anything
in advance.
>>T. C. Boyle: All right. Thanks. Well, you
can whisper into your mother's ear. Is that
your mother [ ]?
>>Male Audience Member #1: My wife.
>> T. C. Boyle: Your wife.
[audience member laughs]
You whisper into her ear about what's gonna
happen. And you remember when you were like,
nine years old? You loved the movie and then
you saw it the second time with your best
friend and just before something happens,
you whisper to them.
>>Male Audience Member #1: I'll do that.
>> T. C. Boyle: You can do that. So, one more
thing about Dave --
>>Male Audience Member #1: This is the good
part.
>> T. C. Boyle: Huh?
>>Male Audience Member #1: This is the good
part.
>> T. C. Boyle: Oh, we're gonna get to good
stuff. No, there's plenty. I'll shift it for
tonight's performance so you don't have to
be too bored. That reminds me. By the way,
I've already made fun of my wife a little
bit now. Now I have to tell you about the
true love of my wife. Sometimes she'll go
with me on tour. She's done it a million times.
Like maybe in Germany, she'll go in Germany
or something. And she'll hear pretty much
the same show every night, night after night.
And I'll look out into the audience and see
her with her head thrown back, howling with
laughter.
[audience laughter]
That's love. That's real love. Anyway, Dave
doesn't have a whole lot of love and here's
one other thing he does. Before all of this
takes place, Alma had just moved to town.
She just got the job with the Park Service
and she lives in one of those parts of Santa
Barbara which is a little village. And she
knew everybody in the village. She began to
get acquainted with them and she had her favorite
restaurant, a very nice, upscale Italian place.
She'd often go there alone or with girlfriends
and she felt comfortable there. She knew the
owner and the maître-de. And so, before any
of this happened, she happened to be in a
cafe listening to a folk singer and met Dave.
He's a good looking guy. They're both in their
thirties at that point. And he and she struck
up a conversation. They're both environmentalists.
They love nature. And so, he asked her on
a date. Well, she doesn't know who he is,
though she said, "Yeah, sure, but I'd feel
comfortable if we could go to the restaurant,
my restaurant in my village." No problem.
So they go on the date and they come and,
Dave, well you just heard him. He's little
bit out there, a little bit out there. He
orders the most expensive bottle of wine on
the list. It's 320 dollars. And he's already
getting out of, getting crazy because there's
no sommelier, just a waiter. "Where's the
sommelier?" "We don't have a sommelier." "Jesus."
So, he then, he asks the owner to come over
and the owner comes over personally and offers
a bottle of wine to Dave.
And Dave goes through the ritual. He sniffs
the cork, the swirling of the glass, a little
taste and so on. Spits it right out and says,
"It's rotgut. Get it out of here." All right.
So then, he orders the second most expensive
bottle of wine on the list and the same scenario
takes place. At which point, Alma gets up
and leaves. So that was their first meeting.
That was their first date. And speaking of
love, by the way,[pause] the truest test of
love if you are a writer like me, of your
friends, of your wives, or your circle of
friends, is this. That story that I just told
you actually happened while I was writing
this novel to a friend of mine who lives here
in the Bay Area. She's a lawyer. She just
moved into one of the little towns on the
Bay and she met a guy on the internet who
claimed also to be a lawyer.
Well, and a tall lawyer for that matter. But
actually, he was a short, young lawyer, but
what the hell. They went on a date and took
her to a restaurant and the whole scene played
out just as I told you. They're happily married
now, three children--No. No. No. It was a
one-time deal.
>>Male Audience Member #1: But I just want
to let you know. The wine was bad.
>> T. C. Boyle: Was it?
[audience laughter]
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah.
>> T. C. Boyle: Yeah, but you know. Don't
forget, don't forget the owner, of course,
is gonna taste this wine in the back to know.
Wow. So anyway, my friends all know that when
they will reveal anything to me and they know
that their deepest sexual secrets will be
revealed to the public for my profit eventually.
And that is the test of love and friendship
beyond any I could imagine. All right. So,
let me just tell you a little bit more about
the continuing story. The first third of the
book is the Anacapa story, which I just told
you about. And that sets up the big fight
to come.
And again, this is what attracted me to this
story. It seems utterly absurd when you have
a closed ecosystem and you add or remove something
that's invasive, you don't know what the effects
will be. And biologists call it a "cascading
effect", where one thing leads to something
you couldn't even imagine. So, briefly, just
after World War II, Monsanto Chemical Company
dumped DDT into the Santa Monica Bay.
The result was, this worked its way up the
food chain. You've all read your Rachel Carson,
'Silent Spring'. And the bald eagles, which
inhabited all the islands, were exterminated.
Their eggs would no longer hatch. They died
off. They are more territorial and tougher
than the Golden Eagle. They are verciferious;
they mainly eat fish. The Golden Eagle eats
groundhogs. And so, in the absence of the
moles, the Goldens moved in. Why? Because
there was a good food source for them.
Delicious, fat, creamy, ripe, little piglets.
The pigs, how had the pigs gotten there? Well,
the original sheep ranchers had some pigs
and the pigs got loose. Now 150 years later,
they were feral. Wild boars all over the island.
Wouldn't be so bad except that, except for
the sheep. The sheep had to be removed because
once it became a National Conservancy and
a National Park Service, the sheep were changing
the ecology. As you know, sheep eat everything,
right down to the root. So, there were no
longer any young trees, or saplings.
All we had was elderly trees, which would
die. Trees are very important on the ridgeline
because they trap the moisture from the fog,
which gives the island, which is rather dry,
some of its moisture. So it's changing the
ecology. All right. So the first thing is
they removed all the sheep. Not a big deal
because the sheep gone back and forth anyway.
They could be trapped and sent back to the
mainland. I'm sure a lot of them became lamb
chops, but this is the way life is. However,
this could not happen with the pigs. They
were a discrete population. They'd been there
for 150 years. And the fear was they might
have developed peculiar diseases that would,
could be communicated back ashore to other
pigs and it would decimate our pork industry
throughout America. So they had to be killed
in situ. So, what happened was, in real life
and in my telling, the Nature Conservancy
and the Park Service got together and they
hired a group of New Zealish guys who specialize
in exterminating animals on islands.
The New Zealish and the Aussies obviously
know a lot about this for obvious reasons.
And at a mere cost of seven million dollars,
they came in, fenced off the island progressively,
killed all the pigs. They shot them dead and
just left them there to rot -- 5500 of them
as it turns out. Why did this have to be done?
Well, because of the invasive fennel.
And I mean, it sounds like something Samuel
Beckett would have come up with for a play.
'The Invasive Fennel'. Once the sheep are
removed, the fennel, the seeds you use in
sausages and so on. This grew up into an enormous
thicket. It's the size of this room, 20 feet
high.
And delicious piglets hid in the thickets
and the Goldens and nothing to eat. What are
they gonna eat? Now we get to the poster animal
out of all of this. The dwarf island fox,
which is four- to six- pounds, the size of
a small cat, through the principles of modern
biogeography which will either make an animal
larger or smaller depending on its availability
of food resources and its niche. This animal
has been there 16,000 years and it has become
a [ ] variety. It's very rare.
And suddenly, they were disappearing and no
one knew exactly why. Well, one of the biologists,
Lois Ramire, who runs the Nature Conservancy
project there, showed me on her computer screen,
a Golden Eagle chick that they photographed.
We love it. I mean, it's just, it's this big.
It's got claws. It's a Golden Eagle. We love
Golden Eagles.
But beneath it were the remains of 20 of these
foxes, one of which had a radio collar on
it, which is how they discovered the problem.
All right. So they had to take all the remaining
foxes. They had to breed them 'cause they'd
be gone. This all happened within the last
five or six years. They'd be gone. They'd
be extinct now. And so, in came the biologists
to trap the Goldens, which is not easy.
This is a big animal, flying. If they threw
nets out of helicopters, but then it falls.
They've actually trapped them without harming
them and take them to the Sierras and let
them go. Meanwhile, they brought in bald eagles
from Alaska to repopulate the islands. And
it's working because I was there with my wife
for the release of the first two bald eagle
chicks born on that island since the 40s.
And again, the chick is like this. And right
now, they have let the foxes go and it seems
that they have been able to restore this ecosystem.
But of course, the question as this book poses,
and actually I should show you the epigraph,
is who has the right to do all of this? How
do we get to be the ones to decide? Yes, we're
the biggest animal. We're the toughest. We're
the smartest. We eat them. We use them for
our pleasure. But look at the rat. What about
the white rat that the kids have?
Living in a cage in a privileged position
while behind the walls are their feral cousins
crapping, screwing, and dying every night.
And one is -- we love it, and the other is
a nuisance. So the book has an epigraph from
Genesis 1:28 and it sort ofsets up the thematic
elements of the book for me. "And God blessed
them and God said unto them: Be fruitful and
multiply and replenish the Earth and subdue
it and have dominion over the fish of the
sea and over the fowl of the air and over
every living thing that moveth upon the Earth."
So I start from that proposition and try to
examine this. Can I make a story out of it.
This is simply the way, for better or worse,
my brain works.
I can't really do deep thinking unless I'm
actually writing something. People see me
on the street and they think, "Oh, there he
goes. He's probably thinking deep thoughts
and coming up with his next novel." No, I'm
just like all the rest of you. When I'm walking
down the street, I'm thinking, "Kill. Screw.
Eat. Kill. Screw. Eat."
[audience laughter]
Exclusively, you know? I can only think about
issues like this. When I'm in the middle of
some complex story and I never have an outline,
I don't know what it's going to be. It just
evolves organically as I go on day by day
over the course of a year. And I think all
these artistic questions and structural questions
and thematic questions resolve themselves
on an unconscious level. So all of that said,
and we have some time left. I mean, I could
read the entire novel to you except the last
paragraph.
[laughter]
Or we could do questions. Then I can save
this wonderful story for people who might
be going to the gig tonight to have something
that's fresh and beautiful.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Sure. Really?
>> T. C. Boyle: Yeah, really.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah.
>> T. C. Boyle: Yeah. How much time do we
have? Do we have 20 minutes more? Do you wanna
ask questions? I mean, how are we gonna so
this? It's up to you.
>>Female Presenter: 20 minutes. The story
that you were gonna tell. Certainly that will
leave time for questions.
>> T. C. Boyle: Well, maybe not.
>>Female Presenter: Maybe not.
>>T. C. Boyle: The story is 400 pages long.
>>Female Presenter: Oh.
[laughter]
>> T. C. Boyle: I mean, do we have to exactly
have an hour, or can we run over?
>>Female Presenter: Well, there's another
meeting coming in at 1:00.
>> T. C. Boyle: Oh, another meeting. By the
way, remember I told you how lucky I am? Yes,
I'm a professor, but I don't go to meetings.
I can't bear meetings, I can't, I'm sorry;
I don't care what anybody else says. I don't
want to hear them, I don't want their opinions.
I'm not a team player, I never will be, I'm
sorry. So, I feel lucky. I don't have to go
to meetings.
>>Male Audience Member #1: That's a lot like
the meetings I go to.
>> T. C. Boyle:
Is it?
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah.
>> T. C. Boyle: Really? Everybody feels the
same way. I think instead of reading you another
story, I just want to talk to you and take
your questions. How's that? But I know there
are a lot of engineers in the room. Please
no math questions. Throw it out. Come on.
Give me something. Anything you wanna know
about in regard to this or the dwarf foxes.
>>Male Audience Member #2: So, you're speaking
to your method for writing novels. How is
that different in terms of thought processes
for short stories you write? Is it just an
inkling of an idea and you just develop that.
When you write, when you come up with an idea,
how do you decide, "Oh, this is a short story,"
versus, "I'm gonna go more further into?"
>> T. C. Boyle: I can see that we're not,--
>>Female Presenter: Can you repeat the question?
>> T. C. Boyle: Yeah, I can see we're not
all engineers in the room.
[laughter]
Writers. Yeah, I'll wait for these poor guys,
way over here. Where are these guys anyway?
>>Male Audience Member #1: I think they're
in Santa Monica.
>>Female Presenter: Santa Monica.
>> T. C. Boyle: Santa Monica, OK. Wow. So,
you know all about the DDT in the Bay. You're
probably drinking it in that coffee.
[laughter]
The question was is there, do I have a difference
between the novels and short stories when
I'm developing ideas?
>>Male Audience Member #2: Yes.
>> T. C. Boyle: Yes. They're very discrete.
I never had a short story get larger and become
a novel, or vice versa, a novel become progressed
to a story. I'm very single-minded and I work
in periods. And I will write a novel. Then
I'll write maybe half a book of stories because
your ideas peter out. Then I'll write another
novel and then the other half of the book
of stories.
And on and on and on. And incidentally, the
joy of writing a novel, which is what I was
doing before they dragged me off on this tour
three weeks ago, is that you know what you're
going to do tomorrow. The problem is, anything
that you might tell me or I might learn or
read about, or anything that happens in society,
I can't really use.
I have to put it aside because I'm locked
into some other novel altogether. And sometimes
it might be an historical novel even. The
joy of the short story is anything that you
want to address, you can address over a period
of six to eight months or however long I might
be writing stories. The downside is in-between
stories, you are bereft.
You have nothing to do. You're completely
nuts. You realize that you're doomed. You're
a failure. You've never written anything before.
You'll never write anything again. You're
over the hill. And you only think about a
suicide for the first week.
Then, maybe, a glimmer of a story comes and
you start with a sentence. I always see something
and then I start with a sentence and then
I try to follow that. I might, the first couple
of days I might just get one paragraph done.
Once you get into the flow and your unconscious
mind takes over, then the story reveals itself.
You find the ending. It might take another
two weeks. Then you have the dead week at
the end where you're trying to figure out
what you're going to do with your life. And
this is of course why all writers are drug
addicts and alcoholics, and why they beat
their wives, their children and their dogs.
Except for me. I'm exceptional.
[pause]
Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #3: You were talking
about an idea intrigues you and then you sort
of process it by writing a novel about it.
So, for instance, this story about this island.
There's a lot of parts, I guess there's conflict
sort of inherent in it. But it’s not necessarily
a story like with a complete arc. How do you
construct the story arc out of all these different
parts?
>>T. C. Boyle: Um hmm.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Another writer
here.
>> T. C. Boyle: Great. The question for you
guys in Santa Monica. Is it about, there's
a lot of disparate elements in here. How do
I construct just a narrative out of the whole
thing? I don't know. I don't know. It's everybody
has some kind of gift and this is my gift.
I don't know how I do it. There's a deep structure
that has to reveal itself.
An example of another way of working. I was
going off on tour a couple years ago. And
forgive me. My entire life is book tours.
It's all I know about.
And I just met with a grad class the week
before. I just met two of the students. And
they came in just to chat with me to get acquainted.
And each said, "Yeah, I'm writing a novel
but I'm having trouble." And I said, "Well,
okay. Great. We'll work on that. How far along
are you?" They said, "Like, 300 pages." I
say, "Great, wonderful."
But they're not connected pages. They've written
the kitchen scene because they love the kitchen
scene, but it's sitting there to be stuck
in somewhere. I don't think it’s supposed
to work that way. I think it has to be organic,
as I've said. It has to evolve as you go along
and discover what it is. So, this is the way
I work. It's the only way I know how to work.
[pause]
Yeah.
>>Female Audience Member #1: Speaking of structure,
one of my favorite novels of yours is 'The
Women'. In that, I found the structure fascinating
because you end with Mamah's story and that's
actually really quite early on in Frank Lloyd
Wright's life. How did you, I mean, I have
my own theories on why you ended with Mamah's
story, because he just goes on to do so many
great things after that, and really, he had
no right to do that.
>> T. C. Boyle: Yes.
>>Female Audience Member #1: So I'm kind of
interested. Can you address how you initially
wrote that story of Frank Lloyd Wright? Did
you have that structure in mind?
>> T. C. Boyle: Sure. What a great question.
For everybody else who's not hearing this
question, there's a lot of praise involved.
I mean, we've just had several paragraphs
of praise of how wonderful I am.
[laughter]
But I won't get into that. It's a question
about the structure of 'The Women', my last
novel before this, which deals with the entire
life and career of Frank Lloyd Wright, primarily
though, as seen through the point of view
of his four women in his life: his mistress
and his three wives. And it also runs backwards
so that you begin with his last wife and go
down the ladder to the death of Mamah.
Well, for obvious reasons, I could then end
climactically with the murder of Martha Borthwick
Cheney. She was killed with a hatchet by a
crazed servant. Her two children were killed,
also. And also several other workers and the
house was burned down. What's so interesting,
as you say, is that Frank Lloyd Wright was
not there that day because he was doing the
Midway Gardens in Chicago and commuting back
and forth. And he was trying to get this thing
onto deadline and get it built.
Had he been there, he well could have been
killed and there would have been nothing beyond
1914. So there's all of that. Well, as soon
as I discovered this structure, and of course,
I had a structural idea in the beginning,
which I didn't have with this cause each one
is different.
[pause]
I could meditate on what love relationships
are. How, not me, of course, but I'm sure
all of you maybe had more than one relationship
in your life, where you're in love and it's
this great thing.
You wanna spend every second with your inamorata
and it's so great. But maybe after a while,
you fall apart and maybe it goes sour. Maybe
it even gets antagonistic. So I was able to
show, by going backwards, each of them. Like,
to begin with, Olgivanna, his last wife was
there and he's in love with her, but he's
being pursued by his previous wife, Miriam.
Miriam is this virago. She's a lunatic. She's
horrible. But then, as we go backwards, we
see Miriam in a new light, when he first meets
her and she's so sexy and enchanting and that
enables me to play with the idea of what relationships
are.
Then again, I'm using real material. I love
the real history, or the real biology. I'm
just dramatizing it. So Miriam, in real life,
and in my telling, came to Frank Lloyd Wright
and after the death of Mamah. She'd been murdered.
Taliesin Center had been burned down. He got
lots of sympathy. He got letters from all
over the world, thousands of them.
'Cause he was pretty well-known at this point.
One came from Miriam Maude Noel. She was around
his age, which was late 40s at that time.
She was an elegant and beautiful woman.
[pause]
Widowed. She'd been living in Paris for the
last ten years. But World War I drove her
back to live in this miserable room in Chicago
with her daughter.
And he liked her letter so much, he agreed
to meet with her on Christmas Eve, in his
office in Chicago, their first meeting. And
she swept in wearing her sealskin coat and
this beautiful hat and these boas and everything
else and had a lorgnette and a cigarette in
a holder. And she just talked breathlessly
to him about love and passion and poetry and
everything else, on and on and on. He was
mesmerized by her.
Then she paused for breath and said, "So,
how do you like me?" And he said, "I've never
seen anything like you." Boom! Wow, that was
it. What a relationship. Also, I got this
information from his own autobiography. But
what do you do with it? And I just structured
it. So, each one is different and each one
has its own [audience member sneezes] [ ]. And
you're right to ask this question because
in that case, I had a structural idea to begin
with.
>>Male Audience Member #4: So, which of the
books have [audience member coughs] less of
that historical aspect? I can think of maybe
'Drop City' having less of that Or do all
of them have some kind of factual base that
you're drawing from?
>> T. C. Boyle: The question is which of the
books [audience member coughs] have less of
the history or less of factual? I rotate always
between different sorts of things, just to
keep myself fresh and to keep the audience
fresh. So that novels that are just whole
cloth are things like 'East Is East' set in
Georgia. Or there's 'The Writer's Colony'
set in Japan.
Most recently,[pause] 'A Friend of the Earth'.
'A Friend of the Earth', which precedes this,
is also about environmental issues; the year
2000 on global warming, which projects into
2025. And that is just us. And so two of the
stories.
Some stories require some research, 'cause
I set stories anywhere. I have no limitations.
I can set a story anywhere on earth. And some
are just experiences. It requires nothing.
Just you are inspired. You do it. I'll give
you an example. I wrote a story a few years
back that the New Yorker published and it
was called 'Swept Away'. It's a very whimsical
story.
I had read that the windiest place in the
world is the Shetland Islands of Scotland.
Kids, little kids get spun down the street,
cats, flower pots. It's always windy there.
So what fun! What would that be like? So I
wrote a love story. It's about an American
ornithologist who comes to study the birds.
She's kind of pretty. She's wearing a little
tartan skirt that she's bought at the tourist
shop. She's got black leggings and she's kind
of cute. She's just got off the ferry, got
her backpack full of cameras and stuff. And
she's walking up the main street. And behind
the window of the main street are all the
local slugs who live there drinking beer.
And it turns out that one of them is Robbie
Bakey and he's never had a girlfriend in his
life. He's never done anything with his life.
He's lived on his family's sheep ranch and
so on.
And his cat is out there trying to catch pigeons.
It's a big cat, not like the cats we were
talking about, the foxes we were talking about.
This is a 14-pound cat. It's blown off by
a gust and it cracks Julie [ ] right in the
head and she's knocked out unconscious on
the road. And at that point, old Duncan Stauer,
the oldest guy on the island, is coming in
his car, his ancient car, going ten miles
an hour right for her and Robbie Bakey runs
out and saves her.
And so, the romance starts. All right. Well,
this has a lot of local color, this story.
Shetland Islands. So, two years later the
local magazine on the Shetland Islands, 'The
Shetlander', asked me if they could reprint
the story because it was so great and they
wondered how many years I lived in the Shetland
Islands. And I had to point out that I had
never actually been to the Shetland Islands.
But I had been to the Arctic Coast of Scotland
once in Oban and I nearly froze to death.
That was enough.
And the rest is invented. So I got lots of
details of the Islands, right down to names
of characters and so on. And faked it. That's
what it's about. It's an improvisation. It's
a seduction of view. I am inviting you into
this world for you to believe in.
But sometimes, as with the details of this
or with the Frank Lloyd Wright book, the historical
details, I love the history so much. Or here
the ecology, that I'm sort of instructing
you in it. There've been over 1006 books written
about Frank Lloyd Wright. I never realized
the extent of the cult of him until I went
to write this book, wrote this book. But if
you've never read any of them and know nothing
about him, you can read this novel and it's
all true; all the facts are true.
But, of course, I'm playing it for my own
purposes and dramatizing it. You know, history
is wonderful, but it doesn't tell you what
people were thinking. You just heard a day
of Lajoy for instance. You're in his head.
You get an idea of what he's thinking. You
don't get that necessarily from history. So
my fun by going to some of these books is
to dramatize them. What was it like? [pause]
The first book I wrote in Santa Barbara. It's
called 'Riven Rock'.
I figured I would need to know some of the
history of the place I just moved to. 'Riven
Rock is set at the turn of the last century,
and it deals with Stanley McCormick. He was
the heir to the McCormick reaper, the fortune.
A millionaire. He had a big 35-acre estate
and so on. When he was in his late 20s, he
married a woman, also in her late 20s, Catherine
Dexter McCormick, an amazing beauty and also
very, very wealthy. First female graduate
in the sciences at MIT. And I would say he's
very handsome; tall, handsome guy, wealthy,
bright-thinking.
The problem is he had a mental problem, which
was beginning to become paranoia. He was a
schizophrenic. Catherine made the great mistake
that many women do, thinking, "Well, you know,
he's a little squirrely, but if I get him
away from his mother, I think I can straighten
him out." Catastrophically wrong. It was just
the most horrendous marriage in history. To
just give one detail. They never consummated
the marriage.
Stanley was incapable. He became, what was
called a 'sexual maniac'. For 20 years, he
had to be locked in Riven Rock, away from
everybody because any woman he saw, he would
assault immediately. Not necessarily sexually,
but just assault. He was that crazy. And I
think it was because having to be intimate
was too much for him to stand and it made
his mental problems more full-blown.
And if you really want to hear horror, and
this is true. On the day they were married,
at her chateau in Geneva, which is now the
American Embassy. And he was early advocate
of motor cars, 1905. Their honeymoon was a
month motoring through France. Two other individuals
came with them. His mother and her mother.
How could you make this stuff up? It is so
fabulous. And so, to conclude all of this,
I will say, people ask me about this book.
They said, "How do you know that the marriage
was unconsummated?" It's easy. I wrote the
book.
[laughter]
So, thank you very much.
>>Female Presenter: Thank you. Thank you.
[applause]